Social Security is unsustainable created
in 1935 Social Security is paid for by a
12.4 percent payroll tax on income up to
a hundred and sixty thousand two hundred
dollars supporters pretend that Social
Security is like a retirement plan where
your specific contributions build value
over time but the system is a Ponzi
scheme in which current beneficiaries
are paid out of new money coming into
the system the problem is that when the
program started paying out benefits in
1940 there were 160 workers per retiree
so a surplus built up today there are
just 2.8 workers per retiree in a decade
there won't be enough money coming into
the system to cover the current level of
benefits and by law benefits will need
to be cut by about 20 percent or payroll
taxes will need to be jacked up even
more than they already are